my name is Steve Bengston I'm with
PricewaterhouseCoopers I want to welcome
you to our intimate event on forming and
managing boards of directors this is
intentionally going to be informal panel
where we encourage you to ask questions
early and often because in most of the
panel's we've been today and other
events the audience Q&A is the best part
so if you have a question get my
attention and we'll get it to the panel
otherwise the format is going to be I'm
going to introduce each of the panels
just kind of starting here and going
down and they're going to chat about the
main thoughts they have on this topic
both from their perspective and from
things you ought to know if you're in
the position of creating or managing
your own board or being a board member
and then I'll start asked asking
questions once we finish the panel
discussions until I see questions from
the audience and with that Diane I guess
you get the favorite position where that
will start with Diane Savage from Cooley
I'm not going to go into their BIOS and
I've asked them not to go into their
BIOS because they are in the booklet if
you have specific questions feel free to
ask them either in the panel or
afterwards Diane you have the floor
first well when I was asking Steve how
this was going to be organized he said
well we're going to go you know from
right to left in terms of speakers and I
looked around and the only seat left was
this one it's open so the good news is
Steve also told me not to be redundant
and that's not a problem for me in any
event I did I
I tried to kind of organize my thoughts
I'm probably the least qualified person
up here to be the first speaker as a
lawyer and having been a lawyer in
Silicon Valley for now I can't believe
at 30 years I have attended hundreds of
board meetings but I have not sat on a
board so I'll be looking at this from
the point of view of somebody who has
sat in a lot of good board meetings and
a lot of bad board meetings and my
observations will come from the point of
view in the perspective of an observer
as opposed to a board participant in
terms of a board member participant and
I really came up with kind of seven
points that I wanted to mention and I'm
sure that some of the other panelists
they corroborate them and others may
argue that what I've said isn't true at
all from their perspective first the
title of this was as I understand it
choose your bosses wisely forming and
managing a board of directors and when I
was talking about this to some of my
associates of course most of the
companies that we work with are venture
backed companies and there isn't a whole
lot of selection involved in the process
of a venture back board generally
speaking one thing that you need to be
aware of of course and I'm sure you are
when you are seeking venture capital and
the VC is doing due diligence on your
business plan and on you as a
prospective investment you should be
doing due diligence on that venture
capitalist as a prospective board member
because that will be your board your
venture capitalists will be the bulk of
your board in the early stages of the
company and more than likely throughout
the time that the company is privately
held if you are lucky enough to be in a
position to do so you will want to
choose your venture capital investors
based on the partners who will be
sitting on your board different
different VCS will bring different
industry experience different
perspectives different management
expertise to the table and those are
things that you should be thinking about
as you consider which venture investor
makes the most sense for you and when
the VC gives you a term sheet and the
term sheet will include among other
things what they see is the Constitution
of the board whether it's a five-person
board or three-person board how many
board seats the VCS get how many board
seats the founders of the company get
one of the things that you're going to
want to do is to the extent that you are
very interested and motivated to have an
individual that you've been working with
on your board you want to see that
person's name in the term sheet so that
you don't wind up in a situation where
you have an expectation and under
and that one person's going to be
sitting on your board and you find out
after the financing that it's going to
be someone else the second point I want
to make is don't make the mistake of
putting your lawyer on the board because
you think you're going to be getting
free advice from your lawyer that
frequently happens in rare occasions it
may actually make sense to have a lawyer
on your board of directors but when that
lawyer sits on your board the lawyer is
sitting on the board as a director and
needs to be wearing his directors hat
and is not there to be representing the
corporation as its lawyer in fact in
those situations where a Cooley lawyer
sits on the board of directors of a
company we will send another lawyer to
the board meeting to act as the lawyer
and to be sitting there thinking as the
lawyer as that board meeting proceeds I
also wanted to mention to you that just
because and this I guess is my third
point just because I'm saying that you
probably don't want your lawyer and I
would argue most of your other service
providers on your board of directors
doesn't mean that you don't want your
lawyer in the boardroom it's a very good
idea especially in the early stages of
company to have your lawyer present at
the board meetings we really feel very
strongly that it's the best way for us
to understand the vision of the company
to understand what you're going to be
doing in the future so that we can be
proactive in terms of helping you deal
with those issues as opposed to reactive
finding out about an issue when it
becomes a problem so having your lawyer
in the boardroom I think is a very good
idea and most venture most of the law
firms in the valley
if you ask for an early stage company
that they're interested in representing
will agree to attend those board
meetings free of charge so it's
definitely worth when you're
interviewing counsel asking that
question and seeing if you can get an
assurance that during the early stages
usually the first year or so of the
company's life that board attendance
will be free of charge
the
let's see point number four I think it's
a really good idea to keep your board
size small for a startup company the
board size is frequently especially a
venture-backed company
it'll frequently be five directors seven
is probably okay as you grow but I think
seven is a large board and I think
things can start to get unwieldy the
more directors that you have and I also
think it's very important to be careful
about giving visitation rights away
visitors of course don't vote at board
meetings but they have the right to
fully participate and they do in those
meetings and so a lot of times having
too many visitors in the boardroom I've
actually gone to board meetings that are
you know where the company is on around
a 4G and you know it's hard to get a
seat there are so many people in that
boardroom and it can really cause the
board meeting to lose focus to be
dealing with that many people even
though the board is five or seven don't
worry too much about giving up control
of the board if you are going to be
venture backed you will be giving up
control of your board and you should
just get used to it and make sure that
the people that are sitting on your
board are people that you respect and
bring complementary skills and talents
to the table
I think Len was mentioning that many
people think that sarbanes-oxley
although not applicable to private
companies is setting the bar for best
practices for companies and certainly
one of the things that you'll see in
sarbanes-oxley is an emphasis on an
independent board in the past it wasn't
that unusual for a venture-backed
company to start off with two or three
inside directors I think that happens
less frequently now it's more likely
that you'll have one founder on the
board and quite frankly I don't think
that's a bad idea
I think it can be very worthwhile if you
have the opportunity to negotiate for a
few independent seats so you have some
venture capitalists represented on the
board you have a couple of
seats and then you have a founder
representative make sure that your board
members are well informed before they
get to the board meeting make sure I've
gone to many many many board meetings
where the board package arrives five
minutes after the directors and it's
very hard for people to be strategic
when they're just reviewing the
information for the first time I always
encourage the companies that I work with
if they are facing issues that they want
to discuss at a board meeting even if
there isn't any material to circulate
ahead of time to talk to the board to
make sure that they're aware of what the
topics are going to be and have been
briefed a little bit on what's going to
be discussed at the board meeting
because that does allow the directors to
certainly spend time thinking about the
issues and just be in a better position
to provide advice during the board
meeting
don't let your meetings turn into
operating meetings your board meetings
turn into operating meetings I've gone
to a lot of board meetings where at
every single board meeting every manager
comes in and presents it's an Operations
Committee meeting it's not a board
meeting boards are supposed to be
strategic as the CEO of the company
you're responsible for managing your
employees that doesn't and and your
board is responsible for managing and
working with you you as the CEO of the
company are responsible for operations
your board is responsible for strategy
and for working with you on the future
not on what's happening right then that
doesn't mean that you can't have
operations people come in and give
reports on an as-needed basis but you
have to walk that fine line and
understand that you shouldn't be having
your operations review in the boardroom
and I guess the only other thing I
wanted to say is I think your job is the
CEO if you are the CEO and the board
member is to manage the board's
expectations and it means that you need
to be as honest with your board as
possible their job is to push the
company to accomplish as much as it
possibly can your job is to make sure
that the that the goals that are set are
realistic
and to discuss as early and as often in
the process as possible any issues of
problems that arise that may prevent the
company from achieving those goals so
that your board has an early heads up
and the ability to work with you on
overcoming those issues well thanks
Dianne next up is our ringer Pascale
Levinson at Levinson venture partners
Pascale felt so strong about this issue
that in November of last year he wrote a
white paper called after the term sheet
or how ventured boards influenced the
success or failure of technology
companies so he is well prepped for this
topic Pascale you've got the floor thank
you I'd like to build on something that
Diane said a moment ago which is really
interesting she asserted that in reality
the selection process for board
composition for venture companies is in
effect non-existent now I think that's
largely true in practice but one of the
premises of the white paper that I
co-authored with Denis Jaffe last
November is that we should all recognize
that the venture board can have a
significant positive or negative impact
on the outcome of the venture back
company and so in fact I would urge all
entrepreneurs to really turn the tables
because the biggest problem I think this
is this is root cause for a lot of the
issues that have haunted so many venture
companies over the last four years is
that people have just thought about
venture capitalists bringing money and
they haven't thought about what else it
is that a venture capitalist really does
at a company and our view and the whole
purpose of the white paper is to shine a
light on how a board can actually impact
a venture company and we have found that
it can mean the difference between a
success or failure because if you have a
dysfunctional organization I don't care
how good that technology is at the end
of the day is not going to matter
because if people can't sit around the
table and help chart strategy
really help move companies forward
especially in an environment by
definition technology is rapidly
changing and you have windows of
opportunity to make the right decisions
and many times boards will be complacent
people will get in to set patterns of
behavior and if you can't break those
patterns you're going to have a
significant problem which is going to
compound the operational challenges that
the company is naturally going to have
so we felt and one of the conclusions is
in short experience Trump's money so you
absolutely want to be selecting the
right venture capitalists to join your
board now what we go into in the white
paper is that you want to find at
different times your companies evolve
and so at different times different
skill sets are required our firm only
invests in companies when they have
initial revenues and initial customers
so we actually don't do seed investing
we don't do a round investing why
well our skill set the skill set of the
partners is best suited to companies
that are in this ramp up of revenue
stage and so we find that we are great
partners with the earliest seed
investors of the a-around investors so
one thing that we suggest first of all
is that companies need to assess what
the needs that they have on their board
and that gets more complicated by the
sarbanes-oxley issues simply because
many companies wish to become public
companies in the future and we have some
families here who have served on and
serve on public company boards today I
know that lend us and one question here
is if you're ever going to make it to be
public at what point do you start
behaving that way you have to change
your culture and there are varying views
as to when do independent directors who
are not affiliated with venture
capitalists when can they play a
constructive role so we've identified in
the white paper we spend 11 months
researching it and and drew
contributions from some of the
best-known venture capitalists some of
the larger firm
and also from attorneys from accountants
as well and the white paper is available
freely on our website at Le BP dot-com
under the news section so the the idea
here is we should scrutinize venture
boards just the way venture capitalists
scrutinized management teams I think
it's a well-recognized fact that there
is self-assessment is sorely lacking on
most venture boards so we identified
what are some great characteristics of
board members also what are some common
pitfalls that venture boards fall into
and we tried to tie it up with some
thoughts as to how you can help diagnose
some of your own issues and how you can
move forward I think I'll stop with that
for the moment
hey thanks Pascal next up is Lynn Baker
with Sutter Hill thanks very much
it gets harder to be redundant not to be
redundant as you go down the line I
agree with everything that's been said
so far one of our portfolio companies
dye onyx
a billion-dollar market cap company with
a great record announced in its
quarterly conference call that it
expected two to three percent of its
earnings over the next six months to be
spent on sarbanes-oxley compliance in
ways that were on items that that would
not have been done had the company done
it itself and that they expected to
spend one to two percent of their
earnings going forward permanently on
things that they would not have done but
for sarbanes-oxley compliance I think
that this has direct impacts and
indirect impacts first of all from a
direct point of view and these are not
scientific numbers but if you just
extrapolated this and by the way these
numbers are consistent with my
experience in the public boards that I
serve in terms of the cost if you
extrapolate this you would assume that
one to two percent of earnings
would would translate into 1 to 2%
subtraction from the market value of the
company the aggregate market value of
the stock market in the u.s. is between
15 and 20 trillion dollars so that would
mean that the cost of sarbanes-oxley
compliance for those things that are
there that are not do not create value
for the company is somewhere between 300
and 600 billion dollars that of course
is more than all of the value that was
lost by all the scandal-ridden companies
so that was more than the cost of the
market lost market capitalization of
Enron MCI and all of the other scandals
even if you assume that the bubble
collapsed what it would have not have
reduced their values anyway and even if
you assume that the market place would
not have corrected some of these abuses
anyway so I think you have to ask the
question what are the direct costs you
have to also ask about the indirect
costs the last public company board
meeting I attended I arrived at 8:15 in
the morning and at 11:45
we finished the portion of the meeting
which would dealt with compliance
rituals and we started talking about the
business and we talked about the
business from 11:45 until 2 p.m. so over
2/3 of the board meeting was spent
talking about going through compliance
rituals and 1/3 was spent talking about
the business not only does this focus
the attention of the board off doing
what boards really should be doing which
is exercising judgment and not going
through mechanical processes but also it
really drives off good businessmen good
businessmen really don't want to spend
their time on boards where you're
spending 2/3 of your time on
non-essential things and we're finding
in Silicon Valley that's becoming
increasingly hard to recruit good
businessmen to be for boards of public
companies particularly smaller and
medium-sized public companies
I think that that we're advising all of
our public portfolio companies to
disclose in their quarterly call what
the cost of this compliance was just
like dye onyx did I think it's a healthy
contribution to the public debate the
point is that the discussion I think
about corporate governance has really
been wrongly focused it's gotten sort of
captured by regulators and lawyers you
know people who are willing to prevent
20 good things from happening in order
to prevent one bad thing from happening
and it's and I and frankly I think
Stanford Business School has sort of
dropped the ball because the issue is
really not regulatory it's not about
compliance that misses the idea of what
boards do it's really about behavior
it's really about and it's about good
behavior I mean the best way to get rid
of crabgrass in your lawn is to have a
healthy lawn and the best way to get rid
of bad behavior is to have good behavior
so the discussion really should be about
how do good boards behave rather than
how do you how do you legislate against
abuses I think you know I would just
make several points about how I think
there's boards behave first of all the
board's main job is to hire and fire the
CEO so you need to make sure that
there's real accountability and you need
to make sure as you select a board that
the board is capable of assessing the
CEOs performance is capable of firing
the CEO is necessary and is capable of
recruiting a new CEO if necessary and
just because you're a manager of pot of
capital doesn't automatically give you
that capability second the board should
be collegial it should operate by
consensus I've been on I guess three
dozen boards over 30 years been to over
a thousand board meetings and we've
seldom if ever have
had a split vote on a major decision
decisions have always been almost
overwhelmingly always been by consensus
and the board should operate as a group
not as individuals with special
individual contributions or special
points of view or constituencies each
board member represents all of the
shareholders and boards should be small
observers are not a good idea
because it describes collegiality board
should be heterogeneous the ideal board
is the CEO maybe one principle founder a
couple of venture capitalists and a
couple of experienced operating
executives not all should be out of the
same industry or expertise background
having a board that's composed of people
that are deep in the technology of the
company is sometimes a bad idea you have
lots of interesting discussions about
industry or technology issues but you're
really not discovery discussing the
essential strategy issues deep industry
knowledge and deep technology expertise
should not be a requirement necessarily
board should add value not just review
criticize and approve and this is really
where there's a big I think distinction
between how healthy boards operate in
Silicon Valley and sort of the
conventional view of how the sort of
conventional corporate governance view
of big companies Silicon Valley is
driven by ownership and it most of the
board members are going to be
significant owners in the company you
want active interest interested people
the ideal board member and in my view is
a young general manager of a best
practices company who's never been on a
board before the not ideal board member
in my opinion as a senior luminary
somebody like a cabinet officer fortune
100 CEO famous industry personage those
kind of people are not likely to dig in
in a small company board what kind of
activities add value for Borden
recruiting helping design the
organization helping set up proper
incentives getting involved in strategy
but board members review strategy they
don't create strategy getting involved
in financing and helping raise money
helping the company with your network
and your credibility
it's the CEOs job to make the board
effective it's part of exercising
leadership the the difference between a
bureaucratic organization and an
entrepreneurial organization is a
bureaucratic organization looks itself
through structure through organizational
charts an entrepreneurial organization
looks at sit at itself behaviorally and
so it's a much more informal
organization it's the CEOs job to inform
and educate the board we have been on
boards where we've got what we call the
mushroom treatment how do you grow
mushrooms keep them in the dark and
cover them with newer it's the CEOs job
to formulate important questions in ways
so as to get value from the board and a
good CEO does it very well and it's a
CEOs job to deal with problem members
and problem behavior the board cannot
pretend to do the management's job I was
on one board where we had a brilliant
board member a brilliant guy
knowledgeable experienced general
manager superb in technology articulate
always had the right answers but the
problem was that the team that had to
implement it walked out of the meeting
discouraged and bewildered after they
after this guy got done with his
brilliant soliloquy and he was not a
good board member it when the board is
designing the product brainstorming and
marketing strategy which it's easy to
get sucked into as a venture capitalist
you're in trouble because that's not the
board's job and finally how important is
the board
well entrepreneurs are the center of the
universe not venture capitalists and so
a really good a really bad board can
kill a company a routinely bad board can
just make a company mildly dysfunctional
except when it fails in its most
important job which is replacing the CEO
a really good board can help somewhat
but its marginal product is not that
great compared to the marginal product
of a truly great CEO thanks Lynn next up
is our entrepreneur representative pavni
diwanji from male frontier Palmilla
how's the board look from your
perspective hi I didn't really prepare a
lot because I was expecting to be an
interactive panel but since I'm probably
the first CEO representative here I
thought maybe I'll talks to some of my
experience since informing the board and
I give you some examples of what really
happens so this is my second company and
we first I'll give you a scenario here
we looked we actually funded the serf
under the company for the first few
months of its existence and then went
and raised money from two top tier VCS
who were very very good quality who are
on our board of directors we're very
excited you know the company is now
getting off the ground
this is our sixth month and you know
we've got a lot of money in the bank
here comes our first board meeting and
we spent the whole board meeting talking
about compensation for the eight
consultants that we'd had which we
hadn't paid for a few months and we
wanted to bring them on board full time
now and at the end of that board meeting
I'm thinking I think it's time to return
the money because this isn't working I
don't know why we're not talking about
the company's future the products why
are we talking about the compensation of
the a plus star employees that are
proven we we I could have just given
back the money except I had my journal
counsel the law
who helped us through the financing on
the side and he says well don't react
pavni you know calm down there are ways
out of this and so then he kind of gave
me some advice and we I did what he
asked me which is go go talk to other
entrepreneurs make a proper compensation
structure chart and then go back to the
board and kind of kind of convince them
through the some industry matrix what
the right answer is the reason I'm
bringing that up is because this
incident was an eye-opener to me one
biggest conclusion that I got out of
that is that a board cannot function
without independent board members who
have operational experience so the first
thing I would say in terms of forming
the board so you know sometimes you
don't have a choice about it like lot of
CEOs inherit aboard but and a lot of
times you don't have a choice about what
investors you bring on board because if
you don't have a choice you don't have
charge but what you do have a choice
about is making a well balanced board
through independent independent board
members so choose them carefully and
choose people who everyone trusts and
can add value so that it's not a
one-sided quote-unquote independent
board member so in terms of what we did
is we added two independent board
members over the next few months after
this incident one of them was a public
company CEO and I actually back to defer
back to defer at a couple of comments
that were made earlier and he he's been
great for the company because when I
have an issue he's a great sounding
board for me because I can at once he
can give me a spot advice on things like
oh this strategy is going to work in
this strategy you might want to think
about blah blah and blah he doesn't get
to devote as much time as my other
independent board member who is
effectively at the GM level at another
comp at a young younger company so what
we I guess I'll go back to my previous
point which is choose a well-balanced
team ie view board as my extended team
and it is really important to choose a
value balance team some of the other
things I would point out is that from
skill set wise and they're focused
individual focus wise it needs to be a
well balanced
so let me give you an example my second
board meeting all we talked about was
product I kind of give a little pep talk
saying we don't want to expend the whole
board meeting talk about comp so come
the second board meeting and all we
talked about was the product and I'm
going well I want to talk about you know
little more than that I want to talk
about distribution channels I want to
talk about strategy for the company and
what marketing campaigns we want to use
and there was a second eye-opener for me
which is it is really important people
tend to gravitate towards their focal
point and if we have two great investors
on board one of them is extremely
creative one of them is very very
product centric person now they're both
they have both invaluable insights but
it's not sufficient so the two
independent board members one of the
things I'm looking for I was looking for
is one of them has extensive marketing
background and it really helps kind of
and the other one is more the public um
the CEO has done sales all his life and
is a great salesman so I'm just saying
I'm giving your spectrum off on how on
skill set wise you can also create a
very good balance okay some of the other
things I would like to say and I think
some one person at least said that you
want to operate by consensus I have to
say back to disagree and I think that if
the board is not asking hard questions
and you don't have any conflict then
it's almost too easy they are not doing
their job so the part of part of boards
responsibility is to stretch the CEO and
management's objectives and their
imagination and so part of flip side of
it is that some conflict is inevitable
and we should expect it and the CEO
chairman of the board needs to manage it
very actively the third thing I would
say is you need to build trust it's like
I go back to it's an extended team and
team cannot function unless there is
trust and so there are various ways you
can do that you know you need to be
always open to their input one of the
techniques that
one of the CEOs taught me that I have
found to be very useful as never bring
cold issues to the board table so any
hard especially hard decisions hard
issues that we want to tackle I always
make it a point to kind of get off line
input from individual board members and
get that perspective on it so that when
we go to the table you know we can
actually have a productive discussion
and we can start with respective few
points versus arriving at them and I
think someone's said giving up the you
should give up controlling the board I
have one comment for that which is
either you manage your board or they
manage you so that's the CEO perspective
of it which is that you need to set the
agenda you need to be very clear to
communicate what the company's viewpoint
on the team's view point out to the
board with that I'll give my thanks pod
knee last up is Kevin F rosy from Excel
who has the enviable challenge of not
being redundant with the first four
panelists Kevin you haven't well before
I get started I want to know my audience
a little bit here before I kind of
launch into some slopes locally how many
of you guys are interested in this
because you're thinking of being
prospective entrepreneurs okay how many
of you guys are thinking of being
prospective board members well okay
sorry board members but not on not
entrepreneurs on other people's boards
okay all right so you know I'll skew it
more towards the entrepreneur but then
I'll try to address a little bit about
you know what you should think of it as
a board member I've been both and so but
I've been on the entrepreneur side and
now I have a pleasure of being on the
other side the dark side so you know and
I'll try to be brief here I think the
main thing for the entrepreneur is you
need to lead that the comment manager
border they will manage you what that
really means is is think about the way
your investors in particular look at
your business and the way we look at
your business is an entrepreneur and it
should be this
any way you look at your business by the
way as a start-up which is what are the
key risks to my business what are the
and there shouldn't be more than three
or you shouldn't cut fund it but there
should there probably three big risks
that you want to take off the table and
I'll try to make this concrete as an
example so the second company I started
as a conical iron planet you know eBay
for construction equipment type of thing
we can also a smile at that idea it's
actually doing pretty well now but when
I got this thing started I said well you
know what are my three top priorities
because we've started from a blank sheet
of paper at a time it was one I needed
you know to recruit the team it's pretty
simple recruit the team launch the
product and the third I had to take out
supply risk which I saw is toward the
big risk of my business I had to get a
whole bunch of supply on the business to
launch and that enabled signs you know
there was a major strategic partnership
I need to sign those are the three
things and how is it and I said you know
what I'm just not going to worry about
everything else you know real estate and
branding and all this others but just
can't focus on it and I got sort of
buying for my board in individual means
and these are the three things I need to
worry about and that's all we're going
to talk about in the board meetings it's
not going to be in the firt until I get
the next stage I accomplish those three
objectives and then you figure out what
are the next three key risks to get you
to the next level so the way we as
venture capitals think about it is what
are the you know what are the areas of
risk we need to take out so that when we
raise another round of financing it's
going to be an up around you know very
simply put so and run your board
meetings in that way as opposed to
making them some you know parade of your
operational executives giving a progress
update because you know that way you
keep your board members focused you say
you remember here the three priorities
let's keep the conversations to those
things I can't emphasize enough how
important that is because your board
members will distract you
and work on the issues that are
interesting to them if you don't lead
them what to look for and recruiting
your board as an entrepreneur to be
honest a lot of it is people who are
willing to will do the
work and work hard in an early stage
people are willing to do the work and
all these other things are important but
if you don't have someone's going to do
the work no the other stuff matters and
it's a lot of work some other areas of
that and make sure their interests are
aligned with yours don't have strategic
investors on your board if you can avoid
it you just don't need the conflict and
they can't it's very difficult from the
where their board member hat and take
off their strategic investor hat so I
would encourage you to not have anybody
on your board who isn't strategically
aligned and the problem is you think
they can help there are relevant partner
in your industry whatever they shouldn't
be on your board would be my advice you
can't always avoid it
but I would look to avoid it and then
I'd say you know after that it's all the
other obvious things you know they have
a relevant network and you know I agree
with the comment about the senior
luminary that Leonard made for the most
part except there are some exceptions to
the rule we have a senior luminary who's
willing to do the work and I've been on
support so they had a tremendous amount
of value but I've also been on others
where they don't do squat now as a board
member what would be the advice I would
have I would tend to agree with with
with Leonard the most a lot of his
comments the board the board's job is
not to run your company and so back to
being an entrepreneur when you're
looking for people be really wary of
sometimes people who just came straight
from an entrepreneurial background and
they're going to sit on your board and
haven't really sat on boards before they
will try to run your company for you
they won't know that they're doing it
they think they're helping they're
giving you advice and they're telling
you what to do but it really should be
more of a Socratic method they should
ask questions
the ideal board members know what the
key issues are and they ask questions to
kind of elicit the response and bring up
the issues of the CEO and of the
management team if they're dictating
saying you need to do X Y & Z you amass
qu eviscerate your management team they
can't make decisions on their own and
they look to you so that's one that's a
be Socratic and then this issue about
hiring and firing the CEO is absolutely
true
in some cases it's also you know hiring
firing the founder which can be very
difficult and that could be a set topic
for an entire topic for the panel and
you know I'm not going to go into my my
opinions on that right now I'm sort of
teed up an offensive issue the panel
wants to take up we can talk about and I
think I'm just going to stop